bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
on va revenir un instant et évidemment
sur le grand oral des manuels macron
hier devant le parlement européen il a
donc présenté sa vision de l'europe est
ce qu'il a réussi à convaincre qu'il
était capable de prendre le leadership
de l'europe lançant chauvet
je pense que convaincre qu'on peut
prendre le leadership de l'europe c'est
par un discours mais c'est en plusieurs
années d'action pour la construction
européenne depuis le discours de la
sorbonne ensuite un travail bilatéral
important avec chacun des les états de
l'union européenne y compris avec des
états qui sont peut-être pas forcément
favorable la même vision de la
construction une dureté dans les
négociations du bric site portait certes
par michel barnier mais au nom de la
france et avec emmanuel macron d'avant
sur le dossier de la pêche et donc
c'était simplement peut-être un discours
pour moi de confirmation d'un leadership
et de la france est de retour je peux
vous le dire à bruxelles notamment
depuis le rexisme mêmes depuis
l'élection en fait d'emmanuel maquereau
en 2017 vous êtes d'accord avec ça on à
l'arjel à la france est bien de retour à
bruxelles écoutez je ne partage pas du
tout cette analyse dans la mesure où le
président macron a brossé un portrait de
l'europe à trois mois des élections
présidentielles qui voulait être un beau
portrait alors qu'il a été incapable
d'appliquer en 4 ans et 9 mois en france
ce qui l'aurait vous est ce qu'il a
présentées pour l'europe hier dans
l'hémicycle à strasbourg
il a évoqué il a évoqué l'immigration
alors que sur le pacte asile et
immigration ce sont 70 millions de
migrants qui sont aux portes de l'europe
et pour lesquels
rien n'est rien n'est envisagé on va
revenir en détail sur l'immigration mais
on va d'abord parlé d aider des grandes
idées qu'il a défendu le droit à l'image
et la protection de l'environnement dans
la charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne et mener aussi une
politique de combat pour l'état de droit
vincent chauvet est ce que on le voit
sur sur le droit à l'ivg et gs que
c'était bien le moment d'en parler ce
que c'est pas une prérogative des états
plutôt
oui c'est je pense une prérogative des
états c'était le moment de soulever la
question d'une part parce qu' il y ait
un débat en france en ce moment sur
l'allongement et on a bien vu la
présidente du parlement lé contrôle ivg
est tout à fait aussi parce que à malte
l'ensemble des forces politiques sont
anti ivg avoir une maltaise qui sur ce
sujet et par extrêmement progressiste et
qui qui a fait l'objet d'un consensus
entre les les forces on va dire central
du parlement européen il fallait
réaffirmer au delà de la personne et de
ce poste kaki relativement honorifique
de président du parlement européen parce
que personne avant la mort
malheureusement du précédent était
capable de en france de citer le nom du
président robin et tout le monde l'aura
oublié dans trois ans cette chaire
maltaise mais en tout cas il était
important de réaffirmer que cette
élection n'était pas un gage donné aux
pro d'oeil aux pro life en tout cas aux
anti ivg là partout en europe le bon
ensuite sur l'environnement les
déclarations sont importants d'un chef
d'état mais la réalité c'est que l'union
européenne j'étais moi même au nom de
l'union européenne à glasgow pour la co
26 ans en 2021 l'union européenne et le
continent en pointe au niveau mondial
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique avec un engagement inscrit
dans le marbre de neutralité carbone en
2050 mais aussi de réduction d'ici 2030
de 55 % les émissions de co2 et c'est le
continent le plus avancé le plus
crédible aussi donc le travail se fait
réaffirmé cette ambition on va dire ça
mange pas de pain mais depuis plusieurs
années d'ailleurs emmanuel macron l'a
rappelé depuis les accords de paris
l'union européenne a vraiment pris un
leadership et là aussi la france aussi
c'était intéressant de voir sur ce sujet
comme sur d'autres le président être
critiquée à la fois à l'extrême gauche
par yannick jadot et manon aubry et à la
droite et l'extrême droite par les
rassemblements le rassemblement national
où les républicains ce qui prouve que
effectivement emmanuel macron en france
comme en europe or cette position d'
équilibre nécessaire on va en parler
plus en détail un parce que ça avait des
allures de débat présidentiel évidemment
ce qui s'est passé hier une question
pour vous andré rouge et vous êtes vous
êtes député européen est ce que c'était
bien le lieu et le moment de faire cette
bataille présidentielle cette bataille
de campagne air dans l'ensemble de
l'assemblée du parlement européen
malheureusement la période s'y prête
le président macron culs nuls
le rôle de candidat à sa propre
réélection à la présidence de la
république française et le président
tournant de l'union européenne donc moi
j'observe que effectivement il a fait
l'unanimité contre lui hormis peut-être
monsieur ces journées qui a trait dont
le dont le discours monsieur macron a
trouvé grâce aux yeux même le très
modéré monsieur randstad weber y est
allé de son tacle
il là il a vraiment été unanimement
critiqués et je pense que c'est
celle à
l'évidence que le président macro on ne
fait pas ça pas l'unanimité vincent
chauvet voulait réagir choix oui il ya
eu des parlers grande famille européenne
rappelons d'ailleurs à à françois-xavier
bellamy ou à valérie pécresse
qu'aujourd'hui c'est là la droite les
conservateurs le ppe qui gouvernent
majoritairement au parlement européen et
en europe et a eu différents types
d'expressions plus ou moins critique
françois xavier bellamy était dans la
campagne mais loin de fred reeber était
était plus sur le fond des sujets j'ai
pas trouvé son son discours insultant
c'était la critique peut être
constructive en tout cas c'est pas la
même famille que celle du présent dans
le public un public n'est pas un
conservateur est un européen c'est sûr
que il fait partie de cette famille
centrale européenne et puis il ya aussi
les socialistes en europe on s'en
souvient peut-être plus puisque les
socialistes ont quasiment disparu en
france en tout cas dans l'est dans les
sondages au niveau de la présidentielle
qui a aussi une expression légèrement
différente il a surtout été critiquée
par les extrêmes au parlement européen
qui représente effectivement délai
courant de famille politique très
opposées de la vision du président de la
république mais le consensus d'ailleurs
et
l'élan que ce soit au conseil européen
c'est à dire aux chefs d'état ou des
gouvernements ou dans d'autres
institutions au jeu je siège au comité
européen des régions qui représentent
les élus locaux de l'union européenne et
je peux vous dire que effectivement il
ne fait pas l'unanimité et heureusement
qu'il y ait un débat d'idées en europe
ça change d'ailleurs de la france c'est
très vivifiant on voit qu'on pouvait
être changée
mais il fait un enfant de consensus de
rassemblement des modérés et surtout des
pro européens qui veulent que l'union
européenne soit nouvelle puissance dans
le 21e siècle a défendu le principe de
non admission des migrants il veut
réformer l'espace schengen il veut aussi
un traité europe/afrique écouter
et la présidence française portera une
réforme de l'espace schengen qui est la
condition du respect de sa promesse
originelle d'un espace de libre
circulation
protéger nos frontières extérieures et
compris en élaborant une force
intergouvernementale d'intervention
rapide
actes et d'un accueil partagé solidaire
entre les états membres comme nous
l'avons fait entre 2018 et 2021
bâtir les partenariats avec les pays
d'origine et de transit pour lutter
contre les réseaux de passeurs et rendre
efficace notre politique de retour alors
on dort et rouget est ce que face aux
défis migratoires qui s'annonce
important les propositions des manuels
macron via l'union européenne sont elles
à la hauteur
écoutez le président macron nous parle
de choses qu'il n'a pas été capable
d'appliquer dans son propre pays pendant
4 ans et 9 mois il parle d'un pacte
entre l'union européenne et l'afrique
alors que cela fait des années et des
années que la france perd pied en
afrique notamment en afrique
subsaharienne et
aujourd'hui il voudrait reprendre or
l'intermédiaire de l'union européenne
cette influence perdue par la france
sur le pacte asile immigration une fois
encore il nous parle de la maîtrise de
nos frontières alors même que l'union
européenne encourage
encourage le lava la venue de deux
micros je répète ce pacte asile
immigration
c'est près de 70 millions de migrants
qui sont aux portes de l'europe et
l'union européenne dont l'union
européenne veut favoriser la venue je
suis là il l'a répété souvent je siège
mois dans la commission du développement
régional et nous avons récemment votées
les budgets pris cinq années à venir
j'ai observé que le budget du feder pour
les régions ultrapériphériques donc les
régions françaises d'outre-mer entre
autres est passé de 4 milliers arh 300
millions à un seul milliard et demi et
cela au profit des migrants pour
lesquels un budget de 11 milliards 3 a
été a été a été voté en commission donc
il ya il ya des couplages deuil un
découplage de du discours du président
macron on est encore dans le en même
temps qui est le tout et son contraire
en réaction à son furet
je sais pas d'où sortent les chiffres de
votre interlocuteur est à part lire le
même budget ce qu'on voit avec l'union
européenne c'est que dans le cadre quel
jeu sièges
écoutez je suis extrêmement surpris en
tout cas les chiffres qui sont publics
ceux qui sont publiés ceux qui sont
votées c'est que avec le plan de relance
européen les crédits d'intervention
régional ont été massivement abondé
ainsi que ceux du fonds social européen
pour subvenir notamment aux européens
qui étaient en difficulté dans cette
crise il ya eu un effet massif et pour
la première fois c'est l'union
européenne qui à emprunter elle-même et
qui a donné de l'argent aux états donc
là le budget a vraiment été
vous parle du fonds feder pour les
départements régions et collectivités
d'outre-mer
et des açores gardrat précisément
combien l'union européenne de nos
canaris et internationales préjuge de ce
qui se peut se passer au niveau de
l'europe via emmanuel macron selon vont
pas alors sur sur schengen il faut une
réforme de schengen bien sûr depuis les
attentats de 2015 et même un peu avant
et ensuite avec le cornell virus
schengen et de fait suspendus vous savez
c'est le fait de ne pas avoir de
contrôle aux frontières internes de
l'union européenne et bien
on n'a pas hésité ces dernières années
même à remettre des contrôles routiers
entre la france et la belgique bon donc
de fait il faut de nouvelles règles dans
un état de suspension voilà quasi de
fêtes de schengen acté il faut
évidemment revoir revoir les règles sur
sur l'accueil des migrants en
méditerranée il ya eu je pense pas
forcément d' approche toujours parfaite
c'est très clair notamment quand on voit
les drames que ce soit entre entre la
france et l'angleterre en ce moment où
précédemment est toujours entre la libye
et l'italie ou la turquie et la grèce
mais en tout cas ce qui a été fait là
aussi de manière empirique ces dernières
années c'est qu'un certain nombre
d'états évidemment par les amis du
rassemblement national monsieur sorbonne
où les polonais mais la plupart des
états et vous souhaitez vous citez la
hongrie il ya une différence d'approché
d'ailleurs qu'avec une et qui complique
les choses en europe puisque les uns
veulent ériger des murs ou des barbelés
quand d'autres valeurs réguler
l'immigration comment comment est ce
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord
vouloir respecter ses frontières comme
le font la hongrie et la pologne
d'ailleurs j'observe que le marine le
pen dès que a été la première à demander
la maîtrise des frontières et je vois
pas ce qu'il y a de soi parce qu'il ya
de 2,2
ira à ça s'agissant de l'est de
l'immigration j'ajouterai ajouté que
j'ai été un des rares à intervenir à
plusieurs reprises
à strasbourg de façon à ce que l'on
intensifie la lutte contre cette forme
d'esclavagé moderne
pièce qui est celle de la traite des
êtres humains que l'on fait venir deux
des pays du sahel vers l'europe par le
biais de passeurs c'est un vrai business
et rien n'est vraiment fait pour le
combattre alors écoutez valérie pécresse
elle a parlé justement de l'immigration
récemment écoutées
il y à 600 millions de personnes qui
rentrent et sortent parents de l'union
européenne dont 20 % ne sont jamais
contrôlé il y à 1900 points de passage
autorisés pour entrer en europe et
l'idée est que les frontières terrestres
puisse être protégé par des grillages et
des murs pour éviter l'effet europe
passoire andré rouge et je me tourne
vers vous parce que vous avez moins
parler que vincent chauvet ce que prône
valérie pécresse finalement le elle
prône aussi le modèle grec c'est ce qu'a
fait aussi la république en marche est
ce que c'est c'est la bonne solution
je suis pas persuadé qu'on se voit
contraint de ne pas revenir à ces
extrémités c'est d'ailleurs surprenant
de voir que madame pécresse il a quitté
les républicains peuvent lorsqu'elles il
était présidé par monsieur wauquiez
parce qu'elle jugeait les républicains
trop à droite prône aujourd'hui les
discours des plus radicaux il me semble
que dès lors qu'
il n'y aura plus aucune attractivité sur
le sol français pour les migrants c'est
à dire que les migrants n'auront plus
droit absolument à rien en termes de
prestations sociales en termes
d'hébergement et en termes de tout ce qu
ils tous ceux dont ils peuvent
bénéficier aujourd'hui
dès lors ils n'auront plus aucun intérêt
à venir en france et que la la la source
se tarira d'elle même
s'ils n'ont plus aucun intérêt à venir
parce qu'aujourd'hui les migrants
viennent chez nous parce qu'ils y voient
une forme d'acte dorado parce que les y
voit un pays dont les dans lequel ils
sont hébergés
dans lesquelles ils sont nourris dans
lequel ils touchent des prestations
dans lequel il ils ont une quasi
impunité
donc effectivement c'est très attrayant
dès lors que cette attraction cette
attractivité n'existera plus les
migrants n'auront plus intérêt à venir y
aura pas il n'y aura pas de deuil aura
pas aller jusqu'à des eaux aux
extrémités prenez par madame pécresse
dans son choix et vous êtes d'accord
avec ça revoir la politique d'accueil
sinon si on veut dire que la france est
un eldorado pas rapport à la situation
en syrie ou en afghanistan
effectivement c'est un pléonasme bon
aujourd'hui on a effectivement des
situations de tension et de guerre qui
font qu'il ya des gens qui traversent la
méditerranée
sur des bateaux et qui parfois n'en
réchappe pas ce qui veut dire que déjà
c'est pas c'est pas forcément simple
quand on met un à un une famille
syrienne où une famille libyenne où des
femmes easy dit de venir se réfugier
parce que c'est le mot et prendre
finalement survivre simplement en europe
et on voit les conditions très précaires
d'ailleurs
d'accueil très souvent donc sur les
frontières extérieures évidemment qu'il
faut que les frontières extérieures
soient soient contrôlés dont la grèce a
des douves naturel ça s'appelle la
méditerranée autour des îles la pologne
a dû maîtriser en urgence ses frontières
avec la biélorussie puisqu'il y avait un
jeu géopolitique à cet endroit là
ensuite le la politique d'accueil des
migrants ou en tout cas des réfugiés
autant à participer à un programme
d'accueil de réfugiés syriens je peux
vous dire que vous savez que enfin je me
porte vraiment en faux contre contre 7
cette idée de dire qui est une
submersion
l'europe nous faire quoi pardon oui non
mais simplement voilà pour vous dire
qu'il ya probablement un certain nombre
de choses à faire que l'europe encourage
pas des migrants arrivés mais simplement
car des gens de pauvres gens avec des
enfants débarquent en italie ou en grèce
eh bien il faut qu'un certain nombre de
pays qui ont des capacités d'accueil
avec des villes accueillantes comme la
mienne va puissent se manifester et
qu'on puisse avoir les possibilités de
faire en sorte que le donner une chance
pour simplement la survie de ces gentils
ces personnes merci beaucoup merci à
tous les deux merci andré rouget et
merci à vous vincent chauvet d'avoir
participé à ce débat ce matin dans la
matinale de france